he be gay a shout-out to our our boy
Wyatt
he's our lighting guy he's a he's a he's
a proud gay man he actually I got his
blessing to tell this story because this
is the funniest [ __ ] so we're talking
about haunted houses that we missed the
funniest part of all oh yeah right
so we're going through one of these
haunted houses and one of the sections
of the haunted house was how to describe
it it was like two inflatable things on
both sides two giant air bags yeah
inflated like down a whole hallway that
were talked like inflated so much that
it was touching each other so you have
to like you have to just like just Jimmy
yourself through this [ __ ] yeah so it's
basically just really claustrophobic
yeah so this like they use this same to
[ __ ] at another one where it was like it
was waist high and like it looked like a
bed of like [ __ ] limbs and [ __ ] I
thought that was cool and there's a good
dude like laying in it like trying to
scare you if I walk past it and it like
it amps it up a little bit somebody
gonna grab my feet what the [ __ ] going
on here this one was like like seven
eight feet high like you're like
immersed in this [ __ ] yeah and it's
going on for like way too long
away too long and I'd like long enough
for me to realize that hundreds of
people have passed through it so that
part actually made me gag because I'm
like dude so many people have just like
like just been through this I just
imagining like just rubbing germs with
like people yeah yeah and so we're going
through it and it's like uncomfortable
I'm like ahhh I'm like this is [ __ ]
nasty
and then Wyatt goes yeah this is what I
what I imagine [ __ ] is like and we were
joking that the scariest thing for the
haunted house for Wyatt was having to go
through [ __ ] get outside we're all
scared of something else and why it's
like as a gay man the vagina part scared
me the mom this is what I imagine [ __ ]
to feel like yeah it does feel like this
when I submerge my entire body in vagina
feels like walking through [ __ ] I think
it was more of the fact sharing it with
a bunch of guys bunch of guys have been
through here before
[Laughter]
you know why it is open of our eyes to a
lot of things he's showing us how
grinder works grinder is the most dude
app [ __ ] is crazy I could not believe it
that [ __ ] is like the [ __ ] is advanced
yeah you can filter by anything yeah a
[ __ ] up yeah it's [ __ ] but it's like
dude it's it's like it's dude [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah you put you brought up a good
point that night it's like straight
dating is like what you want to be
perceived as and like gay dudes was like
no it's like though hard numbers yeah
yeah exactly yeah this tall this wait
when I can [ __ ] where I'm at yeah
exactly like a big straight dating is
like is like yeah you take someone out
and you just you just act like oh yeah I
read a lot of books and it's like who
you want to be seen as okay dating is
just like no it's just hard I'm just
gonna be honest this is exactly who I am
yeah I'm five nine you're looking a [ __ ]
right now then let's do it if not
there's plenty of other people within a
mile of here that are down to [ __ ] you
ever uh you you ever wanted to give a
guy's 5/9 3:20 a [ __ ] no that's fine
I literally have a hundred people
waiting for me that are down to do it I
was like joking with Wyatt that like
gate like Grindr is like like I imagine
like whites DMS are like what people
wish their dm's look like yeah just
hundreds of people being like let's [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] let's [ __ ] let's go let's go
down beside you in this coffee shop
right now you down like when you bottom
in the bathroom quick handy come out are
you down like a regular gay dude
probably gets as many DMS is like a
rapper
yeah Wyatt and the baby's inbox a
[Laughter]
regular game in gets as much asses like
someone like a famous person like works
so hard like to be at that level they
check it out he's refreshing is involved
every time the timer is one second on
every single one of them yeah man it's
like this all day
look at this
and one [ __ ] one [ __ ] you're hot you're
hot you're hot you're hot you're hot
yeah it's like all all day if I ever
feel a little bit down I just 700 people
want to [ __ ] me dice that's that's nice
that's nice I don't need any reassurance
today categories are crazy like how they
categorize oh yeah twinks twonk s' ya
[ __ ] er spares yeah
leather leather that's just just
leathers and bro the look oldest one is
discreet what is that
that's like IC league a yeah it's like
in the closet mmm it's discreet that's
like [ __ ] Ashley Madison tried to
make a whole business out of that
category yeah and that's just a feature
of Grindr yeah yeah yeah it's just a
little just a little on a selection
wheel oh yeah yeah you're in closet yes
fine yeah discreet yeah
well still [ __ ] it's all good no one's
judging literally twing sweet twenty
twinks I'm just thinking Swank Strong's
yeah like what I think I like the main
category than the subcategory yeah gamer
twinks links links gaming twin GA gaming
twins skinny man who could be could pass
his game yeah skinny gamers with the
passes game went blink grassing blinks
wink passing if gamer was a category on
grinder old stuff on my god dude and
that's literally the only non-sexual
category that's the only place that has
like every kind of person grinder for
gamers
you need to find it someone to grind
with mmo's counter-strike fortnight we
got all kinds here and grinder calm hmm
I always thought like forgot who you
with his gay - in my first job and like
I we got some discussion cuz our senior
front-end of like he grinder like
offered him crazy money to work there
okay
and like in the I must make a [ __ ] ton
of money like that's also another thing
I noticed is that like the so one of the
like upsell menus popped up or whatever
yeah and it was like the options for
like account oh he was I guess in like
statuses was crazy like 4 bucks a month
for like you know it was something like
crazy like unlimited dm's and like all
that like the [ __ ] you want the moat
like it's all thought out completely the
[ __ ] you'd want the most and like yeah
up so mechanics we're like crazy
specific and thought out yeah they must
bank wide why it was telling me like you
could spend up to like 200 a year on
that app yeah like like more like I
don't know I think the number was higher
yeah dude
and so my boy I'm not gonna say his name
but he said that in the interview he was
like I don't know if this was legal but
in an interview whoever was interviewing
him kind of like made a statement it was
vague that basically said like look like
we get it like if you're not comfortable
you know I'm saying like or like if
you're afraid of how like working here
will like affect like your social like
image like in your own circle you know
cuz they they're basically acknowledging
that you straight okay um and like the
guy was like but you know we we try to
compensate for that and then my like he
said in the interview adjust the
statement kind of escaped him and then
when he got the offer he was like oh
[ __ ]
oh really yeah the only reason he didn't
take it was the drive oh holy [ __ ] but
he was like dude he's like that number
was insane really yeah like front end
like it wasn't even like a senior role
was like front end like mmm web dev type
work and they were up like are they
independently owned by one of the big
dating I don't know or more I want to
say they sold but maybe not I'm gonna
Google it real quick cuz I do too he
said that they offered him like cuz you
know like front end a web dev there's
kind of a cap on that crunch base but he
basically he got like a senior iOS the
salary offer to him
to do [ __ ] front-end web acquired by
Kunlun damn
Kunlun acquired by come damn how much
was acquired toilets hmm probably a
fuckload of money
they probably banks so much money winder
probably makes a [ __ ] louis shine is a
chinese company so you know it makes a
ton of dollars damn dude
they acquired a sixty percent stake in
2016 for a hundred million bucks
especially not that much not that much
no but I mean hundred mil to get out
I'll take a hundred mil yeah totally
that's crazy yeah so shy don't say like
dating apps are so like sticky wait a
man they're just like sticky it's like
the retention is super [ __ ] high at
least like for people that use them a
lot yeah like it's like when tinder
can't came out with the with the
monetization [ __ ] yeah I was like oh
this is it's not gonna work at all and
then like everyone I knew that was on
tinder was like buying the [ __ ]
premium [ __ ] so they could super like
and all that [ __ ] yeah yeah I don't man
mmm I've never used one Lea never used
one yeah doesn't mean you're not really
missing much honestly yeah not really
there's some people that like power use
those apps yeah but I mean I've never
even went on one tinder date when I was
on tinder damn
[Music]